another thing dr bright is not allowed  to do at the foundation the ultimate  showdown of ultimate destiny is not  grounds to pit more than 15 combinative  scps against each other okay who let dr  bride onto youtube unsupervised whoever  it is you're in big trouble because dr  wright watched the ultimate showdown of  ultimate destiny and it gave him some  pretty destructive ideas watching batman  fight godzilla made him think about  throwing another giant lizard into  combat and he attempted to organize in  his words a grand tournament where 15 of  the most powerful and violent scps would  battle each other in a makeshift  coliseum this is not permitted under any  circumstances yes even if you film it  and post it on youtube